One of the interesting thing about a startup is how is your company going to be organized?
What we now know is the most efficient way to think about
all the pieces just all the parts is by a business model.
And so the next question is okay, Steve just told me think about a business model
but what is a business model?
What are all the pieces? Well let's take a look.
A business model is how a company creates values for itself
while delivering products or services for its customers.
Now if you think about it, in the old days we think about
how to organize a company around functional organizations.
We think no, a company is about its sales department or its engineering department
and you would draw a work chart but now where going to draw a very different diagram.